[Música]
el físico austriaco Erwin schrödinger es
uno de los fundadores de la mecánica
cuántica pero es más famoso por algo que
en realidad nunca lo hizo un experimento
mental que implica un gato se imaginó
poner a un gato en una caja sellada con
un dispositivo que tiene un 50% de
probabilidades de matar al gato en la
siguiente hora al final de esa hora
pregunta Cuál es el estado del gato el
sentido común sugiere que el gato está
vivo o muerto pero schrödinger señaló
que según la física cuántica justo antes
de abrir la caja el gato está en partes
iguales vivo y muerto al mismo tiempo es
solo cuando se abre la caja que vemos un
solo estado definido hasta entonces el
gato es una borrosa probabilidad mitad
una cosa y Mitad la otra esto parece
absurdo el punto de schrödinger la
física cuántica era tan filosóficamente
inquietante que dejó la teoría que había
ayudado a crear y escribió biología por
absurdo que pueda parecer el gato de
schrödinger es muy real de hecho es
esencial si los objetos cuánticos no
pudieran estar en dos estados a la vez
la computadora que usas para ver esto no
podría existir el fenómeno cuántico de
la superposición es una consecuencia de
la naturaleza Dual de partícula y onda
en todo para que un objeto tenga una
longitud de onda debe extenderse en
algún espacio es decir ocupar muchas
posiciones al mismo tiempo la longitud
de onda de algo limitado a un pequeño
espacio no se puede definir ser
perfectamente por tanto existen muchas
longitudes de onda al mismo tiempo no
vemos las propiedades ondulatorias de
los objetos cotidianos porque la
longitud de onda disminuye a medida que
aumenta el impulso y un gato es
relativamente grande y Pesado
si tomamos un solo átomo y lo inflamos
hasta el tamaño del sistema solar la
longitud de onda del gato escapándose
del físico sería tan pequeña como un
átomo en ese sistema solar indetectable
Así que nunca veremos el comportamiento
de onda de un gato
pero algo pequeño como un electrón puede
mostrar evidencia drástica de su
naturaleza Dual si disparamos electrones
uno a uno hacia dos ranuras estrechas en
una barrera se detecta el electrón en el
otro extremo en un solo lugar en un
momento específico como una partícula
pero si se repite esto muchas veces y se
siguen todas las detecciones
individuales Verás un patrón
característico del comportamiento de las
ondas
un conjunto de rayas regiones con muchos
electrones separados por regiones donde
no hay si bloqueas una de las ranuras
las rayas desaparecen esto muestra que
el patrón es resultado de que cada
electrón pasó ambas ranuras al mismo
tiempo Cada electrón no elige ir a la
izquierda o a la derecha sino a la
izquierda y a la derecha al mismo tiempo
está superposición de Estados también
nos lleva a la tecnología moderna un
electrón cerca del núcleo de un átomo
existe en un ancho de longitud de onda
pondos átomos muy juntos y los
electrones no tienen que escoger un solo
átomo sino que se comparten entre ellos
así es como se forman algunos enlaces
químicos un electrón en una molécula no
está solo en el átomo de a o el B sino
en a + b al ir agregando más átomos los
electrones se propagan más compartiendo
un gran número de átomos al mismo tiempo
los electrones en un sólido no están
vinculados a un átomo concreto sino
compartidos entre todos extendiéndose
sobre un amplio espacio está
superposición gigantesca de Estados
determina Cómo se mueven los electrones
a través del material conductor aislante
o semiconductor entender cómo se
comparten los electrones entre átomos
permite controlar con precisión las
propiedades de los semiconductores como
el silicio combinar diferentes
semiconductores correctamente nos
permite hacer transistores a pequeña
escala millones en un solo chip de
ordenador esos chips y su propagación de
electrones alimentan el ordenador que
estás utilizando para ver este video una
vieja broma cuenta que internet existe
para intercambiar vídeos de gatos a un
nivel muy profundo internet debe su
existencia a un físico austriaco y su
gato imaginario
si bien esta paradoja no ha sido
resuelta la respuesta a la pregunta de
Por qué los gatos son tan extraños si la
sabemos conozca más sobre las rarezas de
nuestro amiguito peludo en este vídeo
suscríbase a nuestro canal para no
perderse nunca ningún vídeo